if putin has bad information
for declassified us intelligence
what does that mean for the war in
ukraine in the prospects for
negotiations right now
well i certainly am not a spokesperson
for the kremlin and cannot speak to what
is in vladimir putin's head
what i can say
is of course we have information that
putin felt misled by the russian
military which has resulted in
persistent tension between putin and his
military leadership we believe that
putin is being misinformed by his
advisors about how badly the russian
military is performing and how the
russian economy is being crippled by
sanctions because his senior advisers
are too afraid to tell him the truth
so
it is increasingly clear
that putin's war has been a strategic
blunder that has left russia weaker over
the long term and increasingly isolated
on the world stage
on that i mean in the lead-up to
russia's invasion of ukraine the
administration declassified information
like this to sort of lay out what
putin's intentions were you seem to be
doing that again now
by making it clear that he's being
misled by his advisers
just discuss what's the hope and the
goal in going public with this now
so again i think what this does is paint
a picture of what a strategic error
putin and and russia have made here we
saw from the outset that they for
example made uh aggressive push toward
kiev at the beginning of of the invasion
uh they are now publicly trying to
redefine the goals of their invasion to
be
to be different than they were at the
outset i think
putting forward this information
simply contributes to a sense that this
has been a strategic error for them
again i'm not going to characterize you
know what they are thinking i'm
certainly not going to characterize
how they may or may not use this
information to make decisions that's not
my place
but i do think that making this
information public
contributes to an understanding that
this has been a strategic failure for
russia obviously we will continue to
pursue our strategy of imposing severe
costs on russia uh and trying to
strengthen ukraine on the battlefield
and at the negotiating table and if
putin is being misinformed like this
then who is really pulling the strings
here
that's not a question that i'm able to
speak to from this podium i think this
is a again i don't speak for the kremlin
uh what i can speak to is what the the
information that we see
which again as i say shows that he has
felt misled by the russian military and
has resulted in this persistent tension
how does this impact concerns about
whether you know any deal that may be
negotiated with russia between russia
and ukraine can be trusted
well again we are not negotiators in
that process we are obviously in close
contact with ukrainians as they work
through this process again our role is
to do everything we can to strengthen
ukraine on the battlefield as we've done
with the security assistance the
unprecedented amount of security
assistance and weapons that we've flowed
to to ukraine and also to strengthen
strengthen their hand at the negotiating
table by continuing to apply uh
incredibly severe costs and sanctions uh
on russia
intelligence um is your is your
expectation that releasing this
information um
is are you hoping that it changes
putin's calculus or the military's
calculus as they approach these things
uh it is that is not our intent our
intent is simply to make the information
available uh so that there is a full
understanding uh of what kind of
strategic blunder this has been uh for
russia and for the russian people and is
there anything and more that you can
share just about um you know whether
this is an assessment that you're
extremely confident in i know you know
typically there's a range of views among
analysts across the intelligence
agencies about how solid information is
is there anything you can tell us about
how solid this is and and what is
underlying this that gives you the
confidence that this is the right
reading well i can't speak uh more
specifically to the intelligence because
we obviously do not do anything to
compromise sources or methods i will
simply say we have made it public and
allow you to draw a conclusion from that
so does uh the u.s believe that putin is
now fully aware of the misinformation
that he now has a clear picture of
russia's
military operations and how badly it is
performing
well again i would just say that we
obviously have information which we have
now made public that he felt misled by
the russian military
we believe he's being misinformed by his
advisors about how badly the russian
military is performing and how the
russian economy is being crippled by
sanctions because again his senior
advisers are too afraid to tell him the
truth
beyond that i can't characterize i can't
characterize any further than that are
there any um examples that you might be
able to offer us other than putin not
knowing initially that uh his military
was using and losing conscripts in
ukraine
that
show how putin was potentially being
misinformed by his advisors i don't have
any detail beyond what we've made public
already
there has been so much discussion about
the concerns of over whether putin would
use chemical weapons uh nuclear weapons
biological weapons
does this increase
the administration's concern that putin
might lash out
in that way well as i say i'm not going
to characterize what vladimir putin is
thinking what the kremlin is thinking or
how this might impact their calculus
that is not the intent of putting the
information forward what it does is
underscore that this has been a
strategic blunder for russia
but i am not going to i'm not going to
characterize uh how you know vladimir
putin might be thinking about this i
will say um
that we are prepare for
any and all contingencies as you know
there's a lot of work going on uh to be
prepared uh for contingencies and we've
also been very clear that should russia
act in that way there will be severe
consequences